[ominous music]
- [breathing heavily]
ALL RIGHT, LISTEN UP.
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT'S
CLOSE BY--WE'LL BE SAFE THERE.
- OKAY.
- STAY CLOSE.
- [blows air]
- I'LL GET YOU OUT OF HERE.
- [snarling]
all: [screaming]
[screaming and whimpering]
- OH, MY GOD!
- THEY GOT BRAD!
- [whimpers]
THEY GOT BRAD!
- HEY, THEY DIDN'T GET US!
THEY DIDN'T GET US!
- [whimpers]
- OKAY? WE'RE STILL ALIVE.
- YEAH, RIGHT.
- KEEP IT TOGETHER.
- YEAH, OKAY.
- WE GOTTA MAKE IT
TO THAT SHERIFF'S STATION.
- RIGHT.
OH, MY GOD.
- [gasps]
- [screaming]
- WE GOTTA GO THROUGH 'EM.
JUST STAY TOGETHER,
KEEP MOVING,
AND DON'T GET BIT.
GO!
- [whimpering]
- ARE YOU GETTING THIS?
- YEAH, WHAT IS UP?
- ALL RIGHT, LET'S GO.
LET'S GO.
- THIS IS
SOME CRAZY [bleep].
IT'S--WHAT?
- UM--
- OH.
- AIN'T THAT SOME [bleep]?
- THESE ARE SOME RACIST
MOTHER-[bleep] ZOMBIES!
- WHY WOULD YOU EVEN
LOCK THE DOOR?
I MEAN, THE WINDOW'S BROKEN,
AND--
- [gasps]
- OKAY.
- OH! OH, HELL, NO.
- THAT'S--
- NO, NO, NO.
OH, COME ON!
- WHAT IS THAT?
- THEY SERIOUSLY
WOULDN'T LET HER EAT US.
- THAT'S--
- HEY, GUYS.
ISN'T THIS GREAT?
THESE RACIST ZOMBIES
ARE LEAVING US ALONE.
COME ON,
WE'RE HAVING A PARTY.
[funk music]
- THE BEER IS HERE!
[cheering]
AND LOOK WHO I BROUGHT.
COME ON, MAN.
[cheering]
[ominous music]
♪